jahrelang setzte die deutsche regierung
in den beziehungen zu russland und auch
china auf freundlichen dialog völker
rechtswidriges verhalten
menschenrechtsverletzungen wurden nicht
konsequent geahndet wirtschaftliche
beziehungen sie standen immer im
vordergrund ein fehler wie sich jetzt
zeigt nicht zuletzt ist diese strategie
wandel durch handel weitgehend
gescheitert wirtschaftliche
verflechtungen haben nicht zu mehr
stabilität frieden und demokratie
geführt das müssen wir jetzt bitter
anerkennen späte einsichten auch die spd
war regierungspartei über die
abhängigkeit vom handelspartner china
dagegen redet derzeit kaum einer dabei
ist diese deutlich größer als die von
russland china ist seit jahren der
größte handelspartner deutschlands bei
den exporten steht china mit 103,6
milliarden an dritter stelle bei den
importen an erster stelle mit 141,8
milliarden die deutsche industrie sie
hat viel zu lange nur auf china gesetzt
und auch die union die 16 jahre lang die
kanzlerin stellte räumt nun fehler ein
spricht von rückstand und abhängigkeit
falle es gibt ein nachholbedarf wir
müssen korrigieren wir haben eine
faktische allianz zwischen russland und
china
anlässlich des letzten treffens von
putin und sie bei öffnung der
olympischen spiele hat man dort ein
papier veröffentlicht was von einer
neuen weltordnung gesprochen hat das ist
nicht unsere westliche welt ordnung das
ist eine andere mit der sind wir ab
sofort konfrontiert und müssen
handlungsfähig werden handlungsbedarf
besteht nicht nur beim thema exporte es
geht auch um die beschaffung von
rohstoffen ein blick auf die karte zeigt
nicht die geruchsstoffe gibt es unter
anderem in china australien und russland
in europa kaum china hat in den letzten
jahren stark investiert auch in
australien in afrika in minen in die
verarbeitung deutschland bezieht bisher
alles aus china
wir sind durchaus stark abhängig vor
allen dingen bei den weiterverarbeiteten
rohstoffen und deswegen wenn wir das
erfolgreich hinbekommen wollen bei uns
die dekarbonisierung die erneuerbaren
energien dann werden wir viele rohstoffe
brauchen viele metalle und dann müssen
wir jetzt schauen dass wir da mehr bei
uns recyceln dass wir mehr zugänge
international haben aber auch die
weiterverarbeitung wieder auch außerhalb
chinas gefördert wird es geht dabei um
rohstoffe wie zb kobalt nickel
lithium oder seltene erden wie atrium
rohstoffe ohne die die geplante
energiewende in deutschland nicht
umgesetzt werden kann
abhängigkeiten die nur durch die
erschließung neuer märkte vor allem in
asien zu beheben sind merkt jetzt die
deutsche industrie fordert aber dann
müssen ja auch überlegen wie schaffen
wir es neue freihandelsabkommen mit
indonesien mit thailand mit malaysia mit
den dynamischen ländern dort zu
schließen freihandelsabkommen werden
schon seit längerem verhandelt hat also
sind sie auf eis gelegt weil die eu sehr
hohe standards anlegt mit blick auf
umwelt klimaschutz und menschenrechte
das ist im grundsatz natürlich richtig
los die länder sehen sich nicht in der
lage diese standards anzunehmen und
deswegen kommt es zu keinem abschluss
abhängigkeiten verhindern dafür
umweltstandards aufgeben ein hoher preis
dies merkt gerade auch der grüne
wirtschaftsminister der in katar über
alternativen zu russischen
gaslieferungen verhandelt katar auch
weit davon entfernt eine lupenreine
demokratie zu sein
russland war sehen im auge ist eine
abhängigkeit china ist ein
die ganze zeit schon schwieriger partner
man hat vielleicht in der vergangenheit
zu sehr daran geglaubt dass durch handel
wandelt entsteht und diese naivität die
sollten wir uns glaube ich in zukunft
nicht mehr leisten weiter geht es nach
abu dhabi auch keine demokratie aber
vielleicht reißt habeck demnächst dann
nach indien das so sagt er sei ein
alternativer absatzmarkt eine
möglichkeit deutsche abhängigkeiten
wenigstens zu reduzieren